i think every time we went back the
three of us to our little holding area
and
you know read the news from each other's
phones and laughed and
you know she tells steve lyrics to wwe
what kong's
songs say wap it's [ __ ]
hi you guys oh my gosh i wish i had time
to gush over this show more because it's
so good and we're all obsessed with it
and it's so so so good thank you thank
you so much we love that oh we are like
it's amazing um steve
can i ask you a question yes oh
um you you seem to like the show
and um
i guess obviously the three you have a
personal favorite
oh problem
marty she only has eight minutes oh i i
don't make me choose um steve i'll start
with you the creator of this show what
made the three of you the perfect trio
marty and i have a long history
and selena came in as i would what would
you call it a a pot stirrer you know
it's a different decoration that only
works off screen but it also works on
screen to have a sort of uh commenter on
us older gentle women
[Laughter]
i can't stop thinking about them neither
can i we should do our own true crime
podcast we're gonna go down there and
look around for clues you wanna come
helena what was it like for you to get
the call to work with these legends and
what are you walking away from uh from
this experience with i'll answer that
for her
oh stop no i had i had a great time as
you can tell i could barely keep a
straight face just hanging out with them
it was so wonderful and i learned so
much being around them they're legends
in their own right but they've you know
they're good people humble funny kind
and professional and it was just the
best
i got in the elevator with these two
weirdos then tim got in the elevator
approximately 12 minutes from now i will
be murdered martin how close did this
trio get on set how much fun did you
guys have together and what's your
favorite behind-the-scenes memory you'll
keep um i would say that the working
condition was kind of ideal
um
as steve said we knew steve and i knew
each other for years of working together
selena i never met until i was the first
day of shooting and she was in the
makeup chair
wow and um but you don't know what's
gonna happen you don't know who you know
and right away i could tell
within five minutes she was fabulous
funny loose and wanted
the set to be the way
we all ideally want it which is loose
and a great place to hang and i think
every time we went back the three of us
to our little holding area and
you know read the news from each other's
phones and laughed and
you know she tells steve lyrics to w
what kong's song why did you say wap
it's [ __ ]
wait selena did you explain [ __ ] to them
i certainly why can't you say w.a.p
because that's not what they say that's
not what the kids that's like calling
the usa usa
thank you for this service selena for
explaining and did you what did you guys
think when you learned the meaning of
wap
well i you know i i i've known it for
years that was like
yeah
steve was the part written for selena or
how did she get involved did you have
her in mind for a while for it well no
because you know as a originally written
the idea was for three older people
and uh it was suggested then how did i
get involved
hang on
oh it's cardi b on the line yeah
so it was suggested you know maybe we
need this this type of element in the
mix and you know you usually get that a
um
a list of possible actors or actresses
who could build a part but in this case
we just got one and we have yeah is that
is that possible
wow
selena an instant yes from you
yeah of course i mean just just the you
know what the material is but also just
working with them it was a no-brainer
can i ask i mean as they've said they've
worked together so long we all love
their movies what's your favorite steve
martin martin short movie three amigos
yes
and now she's the third amigo i know i'm
officially the third amiga amiga i
should say yeah that's pretty incredible
um stephen martin i gotta ask you guys
real quick while i have you this year is
30 years since father of the bride first
of all can you believe we don't have a
solution to the hot dog hot dog bun
thing yet
that was the low point
flipping out over four hot dog buns i
think they're working on it i read
recently yeah they're working on it
there was a big protest on twitter
and uh i'm not sure what uh the outcome
was but
one of the manufacturers said no we're
doing it or i can't remember in fact
it's it's smart it's good that i don't
know the outcome of that right well i
was gonna ask they're now doing the
reimagining with gloria estefan and andy
garcia steve and martin could we see you
guys
bring george and frank back for a cameo
at all i don't think it would be
inexpensive
[Laughter]
uh we haven't been approached but i
think that's their project i think they
have a great idea
and they don't need us do you have a
favorite memory from that film from
working on it yes every day
absolutely yeah every day uh well selena
this is your first tv and i think almost
a decade
how how different was the experience of
doing this show to that i mean you've
grown so much since then what was it
like well this was different i when i
was on
wizards it was four cameras live
audience five days a week really fun um
and this one was just one camera well we
had a couple cameras i guess yeah but um
but it was a bit yeah movie style so
there there was the difference already
but i just enjoyed it more because i
felt like i could concentrate a bit more
on the character and um just have fun
with it i i felt like
i could just have freedom to do whatever
i felt like she could do hey tell you
something weird i loved hearing you drop
the f-bombs
i know how to know how to say that word
i was like yes selena like owning this
character she says what like did that
feel good to you to play this character
who was so
in her own um is so confident in herself
yeah i do think a little bit of the
character rubbed off on me because i
feel
um i'm definitely more sarcastic and dry
as i always was um
and i don't know i guess it was just
freeing
yeah
i think it's true though you're playing
more internal
than i've ever seen you more internal
and that actually brings out
more variety it's strange like the
deeper you go inside the more vivid the
character becomes
you might want to write that down marty
yeah okay yeah
write it down more vivid
more internal well so my philosophy of
that more is more is not what you're
saying
no i that first that's not your
philosophy your philosophy is more is
more is more is more
i love that yes and well i asked selena
what she took away from you guys other
than learning uh the meaning of wap
which is incredibly important steve and
martin what did you guys take away from
working with selena well
a tremendous tremendous admiration and
um thank you you know there's three
different energies happening in this
show and her
instinctive ability to know exactly how
to play this character from day one from
the first day of shooting to me was kind
of remarkable because steve never
figured it out until show 10.
there's a very strong chance the killer
is musical superstar sting
the guy from you too
and then real quick how did you get
sting to sign on and where did that idea
come from it's so amazing that sting is
in this show it came from the writers
you know you know in these buildings
like the the arconia represents a you
know typical new york building upper
east side upper west side you do have
celebrities live in the buildings and it
would be natural or unnatural to think
uh
oh
what if it were he
you know our our little criminal minds
are going all kinds of directions
[Music]
you